well as we mentioned collins college
students heading back to class this week
and for families faced with converting
those sterile dorm rooms into some homey
functional spaces with some personal
style that could be a pass or a fail we
talked to a mother-daughter duo who used
their dorm decorating challenges and put
it into a business to help save students
time and money mom karen zuckerman and
her daughter amanda created dormify an
online company that helps students find
their style and maximize their living
space
while not busting the family budget
getting dorm ready
when we were shopping for amanda's
freshman dormer and we really shopped
all over looking for
bedding in that required twin xl size
and we couldn't find what amanda was
looking for as far as style goes
so at one point she just turned to me
and she said
we should start our own line and
i said okay and that's how dormify came
to be there's a lot to consider when
you're decorating your dorm room but
where i would start is first by
gathering all the inspiration that
really speaks to your own personal style
so look on instagram look on pinterest
on tick tock start to save things in the
color schemes that you like or even just
in the aesthetic that really speaks to
you to start to like filter filter down
um what you're going to actually
purchase for your room
next i would think about your budget so
talk to your family about budget think
about what is going to last you all four
years and that's where i would spend my
money so that might be a headboard that
might be some really special wall decor
or even some furniture pieces that serve
as storage um and then when thinking
about uh what to split with your
roommate and having a conversation about
what makes sense to both share
i would recommend sharing an area rug
for the space a floor lamp to help with
the horrible lighting that you're
provided and even just some of your
kitchen appliances your micro fridge and
then last but not least storage is so
important i know everyone brings as much
stuff as possible to college and there's
never enough space to put it all so i
would make sure to leverage under your
bed lift up and lock your your bed as
high as possible so you can fit as much
as you can underneath it
and then cover it up with a bed skirt so
you don't just see everything that you
put under there
all right so the guy students may need a
little help with that mom if you could
help with the bed skirt cover up the
storage i scanned their website i saw a
30 off sale that's happening right now
there were lots of good space saving
ideas lots of colors and styles for
bedding accessories room organizing so
you can go to our website
eightnewsnow.com for the dormify and
they also have a link to an e-line
textbook company called pearson that has
some good ideas to save you money on
textbooks as well john i wish i had seen
dormify when i was in college because my
room looked a little more like alcatraz
than uh
college oh gee i wish i had been your
roommate
5